okay so welcome to my clarification
video for my rubik's beginner tutorial
steps 1 & 2 I've received some
frequently asked questions and problems
from viewers that I'd like to address in
this video what I'm going to do is sort
of a walk through for the first two
steps first forming the cross and then
solving the bottom layer this video is
not meant for you to follow along but
instead to learn some different cases
that you may see while solving your own
cube this should hopefully give you a
better understanding for solving the
first bottom layer alright so you have a
mixed-up cube in front of you now what
is the very first thing that you want to
do when you're solving the cube the very
first thing that I do is I arrange it so
that the white center sticker is on the
bottom and the yellow center sticker is
therefore on top and I solve the white
side completely first and then I work my
way up to the top of the cube now you
can pick two other colors if you like if
you wanted to pick green and blue or red
and orange that would be perfectly fine
however I learned it with the white side
on the bottom so that's how I'm going to
explain it now the first thing you want
to do is you want to get the white cross
on the bottom in order to do that what
we first do is we put four white edge
pieces around the yellow Center in these
four positions when you do that you're
going to get a cube that looks just like
this one now the reason that we put them
on the top instead of putting them
directly on the white face is because
that we need to match up each of these
white edge pieces to two colors this one
is the blue white this is the orange
white red and this is the green so by
putting them up on top like this we can
match each edge with its side color and
then flip it onto the white side without
interfering with the rest of the edges
okay so once you get a cube that looks
like this one I'm not going to go into
too much detail on how to do this I do
explain this in step one and step one be
in my tutorial so you have a mixed up
cube you want to hold white on the
bottom yellow on top now you want to
look in the middle layer four white
edges because you can flip that directly
up now I have another one so I need an
empty spot here so
I'm going to turn this piece out of the
way so I have an empty spot here and now
I can flip this up look around I happen
to have another one right in that spot
so all I have to do is get another empty
spot here by turning this layer and now
I have an empty spot so now I can flip
this piece up look around again where is
that last white edge piece well it's
right here it is in the middle layer so
all I have to do is get an empty spot
here so that I could flip this up
because you don't want to kick this out
because then you'll still have three so
you just turn this around turn the top
face just like that and now you can pop
this into the empty spot so now you have
those four white edge pieces around the
yellow Center now what you want to do is
you want to flip each of these edge
pieces on to the white side now in this
case I do happen to have each of these
white edge pieces matched up but that
rarely occurs another case that you'll
have is probably something similar to
this so you have the four white edges
and each of these has its own color on
the side as you'll see this white red
piece is matched up with the red so all
you have to do is once it's matched you
flip this front face now you turn it
twice so that this white sticker goes on
to the white face so you match the red
first on the side and then you flip this
piece upside down so that White's
matching white do that for the remaining
three you have to match each one
individually if you have to match the
same time that's fine you can flip those
two but you still have to match the
remaining ones so here I have a green
turn it and match it and then flip it
flipped and matched okay so you match
this one now blue to blue and then white
to white so now I want to get this white
sticker down here so I flip it do the
same thing for the remaining one the
remaining one is actually already
matched up with the orange but let's say
it's not it's over here what you want to
do is you want to turn the top face
until this orange sticker is matched
with its center color once it's like
that all you have to do is flip this
front face twice so that this piece here
the white orange piece goes upside down
so you're seeing a turn and now if you
look on the bottom you'll see that you
have a white cross now each of these
pieces must be matched up to two of its
respective Center so this is the white
green it's matched up with the green and
white this is matched with orange white
blue and red so once you have the cross
then you're ready to go on and solve the
remaining four corner pieces to complete
the bottom layer if you don't have your
cross match correctly you're not going
to see the upside-down color T's that I
explained at the end of the second step
so please make sure that you have a
correct cross and then we're going to go
on to place the four bottom white corner
pieces in these positions now to place
the white corner pieces what we want to
do first is we want to look in the top
layer in these four positions for any
corner pieces that have a white sticker
so if we look around this doesn't have a
white sticker no white sticker this one
has a white sticker and this one also
has a white sticker but as you'll notice
these two have white stickers on
different faces this white sticker is on
the side of the cube while this white
sticker is on top of the cube so we can
work with the ones that have white
stickers on the side however the ones
that have white stickers on the top need
to be fixed so that they have white
stickers on the side so if you do have a
white sticker on the side though what
you can do then is to look at the other
color that is on the side with white
next to it so this color is blue don't
pay attention to the top color so once
you look at the color on the side with
white you want to match that sticker up
with its center color diagonally so we
want the blue to be matched with the
blue so we turn the top around twice
until it's matched then we hold that
Center that we just matched towards us
just like I'm holding here and then you
look at the white sticker is it facing
the left or is it facing the right those
are the only two possibilities once you
have it matched so as you'll see it's on
the left so we're going to do the move
that corresponds with the left side in
order to put this P
right here so we do left up or counter
clockwise top counterclockwise to bring
this piece towards you and then left
down or clockwise and as you'll see that
corner piece has now been placed
correctly in between its three Center
colors so looking again on top of the
cube we see that we have that piece that
has the white sticker on top so to fix
this what we want to do is we want to
place it directly above a piece that has
not been properly oriented since we only
did this one so far
we just want to make sure that this
piece is not above this corner when
we're placing when we're fixing this
piece so it's above a corner that
doesn't really matter it's not placed
correctly so we're going to do this move
put this piece directly in front of you
just like this and on the right then
you're going to do right face clockwise
or up top twice and then right face
counterclockwise or back down and what
that has done is it brought this piece
so that it is fixed and it has a white
sticker on the side so what we do with
this piece now you look at the other
color that is on the side with white
which is green and you match it up now
since white is facing the right we do
the opposite or mirror image move of the
one we did on the left so we take this
piece make sure that green is facing
towards you hold the piece you bring it
up bring the piece towards you and bring
the piece back down so now we have to
look again and we have two pieces on top
that need to be fixed so we put them
above empty spots which they already are
and then we do that move to fix these
corner these corner pieces that have the
white sticker on top so we hold it in
front of us we do up turn the top twice
and then bring the right face down and
as you'll see that actually fixed both
of the pieces look at the other color
that's on the side with white now which
is red match red white sticker is facing
to the right so we hold the red Center
first towards us then we bring this
piece remember we want to get this piece
down here so
bring it up bring the piece towards you
by turning the top face clockwise and
then bring the right face back down or
counterclockwise so now we have one two
and three now the last one is right here
and that has red on the side with white
so what we want to do is just turn the
top until the red sticker is matched
diagonally with its center now when
you're holding the red center the yeah
the white sticker is facing the left so
we do the move with the left side it's
just the same moves over and over again
so bring the left side counterclockwise
or up bring the top base
counterclockwise and now this piece is
lined up with the other whites and then
you bring the left side back down and as
you'll see the white bottom is completed
and if you hold the cube upside down you
do see these color cheese so this one's
green red blue and orange